great gesture by Peter King if you read
the Monday Morning Quarterback the mmqb
you'll know what he's doing with his
good friend Paul Zimmerman longtime NFL
writer and he needs help he needs help
with some of the cost for his health
care and Peter's doing a wonderful thing
with a GoFundMe page Pete let me start
there with dr. Z if you'll let the
audience know how they can help well Dan
thank you and I appreciate you giving me
this forum basically Paul Zimmerman
eight years ago suffered a series of
three strokes and soon we raised a bunch
of money for him to try to get some
alternative treatment to help but dan
I'm telling you Linda his wife has gone
through at least you know 30 to 40
different regimens and every effort to
try to do anything Paul just can't speak
he can't he can't cut he can't basically
process information we used to certainly
can't even think of resuming his career
he's 83 now and he's in declining health
he's in an assisted living facility in
New Jersey that health care regular
health care doesn't pay much of the cost
for so Linden he were good enough to see
me and timro Hannity mmqb on Saturday
and we're going to try to tell his story
a little bit this week in what we're
calling dr. Z week at the mmqb and we've
set up a GoFundMe page so if you go to
my column today which is obviously at
the mmqb com you'll find a link to the
GoFundMe page that we have started for
Paul Zimmerman I believe Todd for it
said that you guys are also going to put
it up on your site uh for the show and
look I you know Paul has had a wonderful
life he's had a fantastic life I'm just
trying to help him as best I can try to
live the rest of his life however long
it's going to be live a little bit of
dignity and some comfort yeah we'll have
the website up on our page our homepage
and also at Peter's website as well a
couple items here the
Johnny Manziel quotes from his father
are pretty startling startling buffet
relief yeah he's a druggie it's no
secret that he's a druggie this
according to his dad he said this friday
in an interview with the mothership I
don't know what to say other than my son
is a drug he needs help he just hasn't
sought it yet hopefully he doesn't die
before he comes to his senses that's
about all you can say I don't know what
else to say how did we get to this point
Peter well you know Dan what I find
amazing i was explaining this to my wife
over the weekend about Manziel because
he's such an amazing story you know and
I was telling her how his teammates are
but von Miller absolutely loves Johnny
Manziel the Detroit Lions picked a long
snapper this year from ke who would you
know basically grown up in Texas and
knows Johnny so well the city drop
everything to go help Johnny people have
been around him in who have been
teammates of them absolutely love this
guy he's a great friend a great teammate
but he's got this demon that he just
simply can't get rid of and you know to
me dan I think what his father says is
right I think the best place for right
now would be uh in some uh some some
drug program and if it has to be uh you
know behind bars then so be it but he's
obviously not going to be able to do
anything with his life until he can
until he can like this I mean I've heard
a bunch of people saying you know well
you know just get him back in the
structure of a football team and he'll
be okay well it's never worked before
the al jazeera HGH story course attached
to peyton manning but now that he's
retired we've moved it to shifted it to
Julius Peppers also Clay Matthews some
baseball players in there but the NFL
says the Players Association has been
stalling preventing the NFL from
interviewing these players what's the
next step what happens with these
players in this report well I think what
happens is if Tom pehle Sarah wrote in
USA Today the other day is that when
when Clay Matthews Julius Peppers uh
James Harrison arrived at training camp
this year they should expect uh to be uh
to be interviewed or at least to be
attempted to be interviewed by a an
investigative person from the lead to
ask him I'd ask them about the Al
Jazeera report Mike Neal formerly
attackers is now a free agent belief
says will be interviewed before them and
you know I think I've been wondering
what is the league waiting for solar
league claims it's the NFLPA and and you
know look I think a lot of people might
come down and say well you know the
NFLPA is being obstructionist and I
guess you could argue that but you know
the bottom line is then the NFLPA just
simply does not trust with the NFL I has
done and is doing uh it you know in it
investigations and so I think the
stalemate here is going to continue the
next step is we'll see how players react
when it has to hear show up on their
doorstep in Green Bay in Pittsburgh a
month from now he's Peter King the mmqb
calm also NBC's football night in
America couple of the things I saw where
the Eagles are basically going to have
Carson Wentz go through all of this but
then not having active during the season
so you're going to have I mean they
spent money on Bradford and chase daniel
but Carson Wentz not playing this year
is the game plan I think it's easy to
say on jun 26 27 whatever it is that uh
that Carson Wentz is going to be the
backup the whole year and he very well
could be I mean it worked with the
Bengals and Carson Palmer now thirteen
years ago in his rookie year he
basically set boxed and so it very well
could happen but I mean look Doug
Peterson's not stupid if they go to
training camp and Carson Wentz is on
fire and playing significantly better
than one or both of those guys he's
gonna be active on Sundays now do I
expect it to happen not it be not at the
beginning of the season but I think it's
so i think it's i mean if i were if i
were a betting man I would not bet that
if all three men were healthy for 17
weeks this year I would not bet that
Carson Wentz would be inactive 17 times
are 16 times ER yeah the best-case
scenario is you get Bradford playing
well and then you get some trade
opportunities with him uh the the Tom
Brady court decision happening anytime
soon I you know I saw Mike wreath wrote
this yesterday on ESPN boston and i
think it was a smart thing basically
said that back when when this case uh
was filed uh you know with the Second
Circuit US Court of Appeals that
basically they were they were told that
it was going to be four to six weeks
while we write me to that curve right
now in the fifth week and so it makes
sense a decision could come this week
and if they would do it the way the NFL
does things they do it at 459 p.m. on
friday so lovely bow out of the holiday
weekend doors okay you know but but I a
it would surprise me but still you know
obviously it's a long shot that the case
is going to be heard but I still think
that it's it's a very very anxiously
awaited decision by the Second Circuit
Pete good to talk to you and continued
great work with dr. Z we appreciate it
and hopefully people be able to go to
the website to contribute hey thanks a
million Dan really appreciate you giving
it that exposure that's a Peter King you
can go to the mmqb com to Lauren learn
more about helping a doctor Zeke the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience